okay four folks joining this livestream
we are talking about features for the
upcoming version wolf language that
involve functions that return results
that involve uncertainty and certainly
being represented by our around wrapper
so let's take a look at an example here
so the age of the earth which is not
precisely known exactly so the two big
groups of functions one of the two big
groups of functions is is one from alpha
returning results with explicit errors
in this and some mm-hmm so currently
this is being done using precision
numerical precision yes and it is not
completely stupid by the way no I mean
this is something that can store the
information needed the only issue is
then that when it's propagated it
doesn't follow the rules of then
certainty right we want it to be
propagated what is the difference
between precision propagation rules and
uncertainty propagation rules the
uncertainty probations rules assume a
normal distribution so it's all the
square roots of squares of derivatives
okay whereas intervals and it's time to
always get the interval that would cover
I see so it's it's like one of them is a
box distribution and the other one is
some kind normal as a normal
distribution right yeah and and the
precision case isn't worried if it goofs
up and makes its box a bit bigger than
it should have been yes and in fact
there are some cases in which it depends
on the formula the the uncertainty one
maybe a bit larger in some cases in
which the second derivatives enter a
game etcetera so yeah so here we see how
this would be
represented with with a ring and you see
that this is using a regular type
setting in which the arrow is
represented in smaller and centered the
fact that is smaller it looks nice
I'm not so sure I I don't get used to
the fact that this Center I agree
doesn't look right if it's followed by
something it looks misplaced
you know there's anybody from design on
this call I don't think so because this
was going to be a more no I I think they
should try it without it centers and I
think also it stupid distance before the
plus minus is too large and I agree with
you that it needs some friends maybe
light gray parens of some kind mm-hm
yeah in this case I copied from the
Wikipedia some similar results and they
don't use parentheses but I've seen
parentheses used in many books because
it's clearer yeah I think it's clearer I
think if they're light gray parentheses
I think that would look nice I mean I
also point out that where we'd have to
say times ten to the nine years we
really don't have much of a choice but
to use parentheses right okay yes so
this is a question I was wondering
whether there is a connection here
between the typesetting and the actual
numeric errors because right now around
is a well I'm not sure this is correct
but right now around takes a number with
precision and type sets it with literal
I mean converts it into an object what
does it do with the machine precision
oblong nothing there are examples below
so when they are exact or machine
precision it doesn't with
okay but if it's been given a stated
precision seems fairly sensible to me
that it would do that with a stated
precision I mean as you say they mean
slightly different things like one of
them is the you know it's a variance and
one of them is the outer boundary of the
interval hmm so I was wondering whether
it should be our own form which type
sets us the other one rather than our
own itself doing the combustion
well we typesetting are we converting at
the moment we don't even have yet around
form but around is changing there I
think that around taking a number with
precision and being able to does around
have a second argument yes it has all
kinds of yes see I have a feeling that
there should be a string name for the
second argument because here's something
you might want to do you've got this
interval box for the precision but what
you really want is you know 68% of that
or something as the variance do they
make sense or the sound deviation
whatever it is I can imagine wanting a
second argument through a round which is
like the error specification that some
kind of automatic error specification
derived from precision but not
necessarily where the error is equal to
the precision bound I see this Roger
here and can you comment yeah I agree
with you because what our precision
tracking is deterministic bounds it's in
termina stick model this is a stochastic
model of errors and it's unbounded with
a normal distribution it's unbounded
yeah so okay so with my suggestions so
there's a second argument that says
something like I don't know maybe it
could just be automatic and then it
would do something what would it doing I
mean you know I could imagine full
versus automatic
we're full means make the around bound
so to speak be equal to the precision
bound where as automatic means make it
be 68% okay do we need to report
correlations from both now for knowledge
base it would sure be nice but how on
earth would we do it well I guess the
question is here is whether there is a
casing alpha in which we need to report
and around with a vector and then the
second argument being a matrix a
covariance matrix I think Michael will
be the expert on that I mean I would
guess that
[Music]
well I'm sure that when we return back
to things like for example geo gravitate
Geo gravity vectors I'm sure that they
have correlated errors I mean whatever
we're turning a vector it's gonna have
correlated errors I think I see me I
think if we're returning you know I
think that the scientific literature
does not typically contain the
information on you know yes somebody you
know if I look in the particle data book
for example and I look at you know the
mass of the you know F Mazen or
something which decays into this and
that and probably there's a there's a
relationship between the estimated mass
of the F Mazon and the errors of
estimation of some of the masses of its
decay products but that information that
correlation is not reported in the
standard sort of scientific literature I
think making sense yeah so I think I
think it will essentially never be
possible to do this except when you're
returning a vector quantity unless I'm
missing something
do we have anybody from the wolf malphur
team here who would have more comments
about that
is going dealing about this no I'm not
sure any of the domains I handle have
that issue so that you I know malicious
let me give you a case that might okay
and that is in your area which is geo
stuff okay so let's say you say or am I
being crazy well it's a little funky
okay where is that volcano oh it's got
an error of a hundred feet in the
position of the volcano okay but
depending on where you are on the earth
am I being crazy here no near the North
Pole right the error in the longitude
the hundred feet could be a you know 90
degrees and longitude and it's still
only feature now is that representable
by a correlated error or is that
something different or is that just
saying that the error in the when
represented as lat/long that the error
in the latitude is small compared to
there and the longitude
yeah metric or to the none to to
something that we call a correlation
right yeah I mean the correlation look
here's an example I mean but again these
are pretty exotic I mean something like
wind vectors where I mean we just don't
know this people don't measure these
correlations most of the time people
measure one thing typically so I think
it's gonna be very rarely known yeah so
we start assuming that I think we should
assume there's nothing there right so
how do you see the difficulty in
converting the current errors of work
from one fine to alone I guess in some
cases we should visit each domain
because this is really very specific for
each domain to
to assign some kind of special output
and of course we can assign that to
depending on the mathematical version
the user is using because you know is to
support all their versions and these
four new versions of course yeah I mean
this is going to be a long time tail so
to speak not to talk about ones the
molecular dynamics but the the this is
and it's gonna take a while to get all
these done and and and it has we have to
be very careful about this you know
because we've been assuming that the
interval bound is equal to the error
estimate for most in most cases right
planet data we have etcetera and all
these data there are some known errors
for example and as you were saying maybe
there are even correlations between the
masses measured for planets setter but I
don't know if there is any actual
measure of the correlations really and
how would this work be an option in
entity value that says give me the
result with the decision to do so if we
want to start returning the around the
new around object for newer versions of
Mathematica you have to explicitly ask
for it
for which well in the case of well for
now we could probably do that as in the
entity value thing we should probably
have it be the third argument there to
be something like around or around value
I think for the time being because we'll
take a while before all the domains are
moved over right and I think we need to
be testing it on a few domains some of
the ones from physics are the most
obvious I mean you know if we say like
for example
give you an example I mean this is a
this is a very deep rabbit hole okay
because for example the Census Bureau
has sampling errors right which they
quote and but but that's a big mess
because for example it can't be the case
that there are a negative number of
piano tuners in Chicago right so in
other words if they say the sampling
error is plus or minus I don't know ten
people and the answer is five plus or
minus 10 that's very weird so anyway
this requires more thought but I mean
this is not a bridge we have to cross
immediately I think what we do is to say
a round value as the third argument to
entity value and start from from
supporting a few domains that way that
you mentioned many of for domains use
also thanks serious I don't know if we
are going to support around value of
staying serious it's a good question
Roger can you comment on that is it a
back to space it's a water vector space
the set around does it behave like a
vector space yes you can add two of them
and you get another one and we'll apply
them by constants yeah so I think it
would have to be a project but that
sounds promising
it sounds like it would kind of work out
of the box but got to be tested and but
if it's not the vector space then he'll
know right just won't work right okay
for the third argument of entity value
do we have ways of combining them so
like if I ask for into the Association
can I combine that with around in some
way or is that more a Toni question or
I'm sorry say that again
what so we have existing third arguments
to entity value yes yes this is a
typical example of a third argument when
Steve value
yeah good but so for example you can ask
for entity association I see I see I see
you know that's a Tony question I wonder
if instead of a woman they should be
some kind of option but it's not an
option instead but we need to just look
at some cases where we can actually
introduce these folks on our live stream
are asking by the way can I run this
stuff here or not this is in can I only
run the prototype build in the prototype
yes the typesetting will be slightly
different um so the question from our
livestream audience is will a round of
pi return PI and the answer is yes right
a round of PI of the exact PI know why
doesn't that just return hi
well it's lie around pi comma C or some
number comma zero because but doesn't
mr. shusun be there but it didn't fine
so right
okay so D so why does around the PI not
just return PI because this is what we
were just discussing before what's the
meaning of our own with one argument I
see so that's if if we take a round of
so I think the answer should be the
round of a finite precision number
probably defaults to make the plus or
minus be the precision bound right in
which case it would make sense for a
round of PI to just return PI yes but we
were saying that if we have pi with
precision three then it would return
around which is strange that sometimes
it returns a number sometimes another
I sort of think one hour around is kind
of silly anyway
well fine maybe we shouldn't have it in
Ashley oh that is magnificent
now explain it to me why does it have
these things at the top wires there it's
only I don't understand there's no
uncertainty in the in the x-axis why
does it have why does it have things
that look like star starving I think
that they're a little big okay if you
throw pretty hasn't been tuned oh yeah
but why does it have serifs that's one
of the styles there's my I know yeah I
know they're common but I mean do we
want that as the default I contend I
think it looks weird without some sort
of serif but I suppose if I might come I
said okay so let's say that's fun
it's I think the serfs are too big
because I think what you end up with
those degenerated ones are really
looking silly there he sets error
functors re error bar function goes to
the string bars
I think that's significantly better I
mean I certainly prefer that let's make
the errors of the bigger why why does
some of them is that an aliasing problem
why does some of them no no I don't
think that's what I've seen when I've
done this recently so try making it
bigger see what happens may be anything
but it's very weird yes like it it's a
fractional number of pixels wide or
something you have 150 s magnification
maybe three 200 to see if that's the
actually 100 it's probably no you are
you are correct although now there's a
new problem which is those things aren't
centered in the phone lines
okay so there's simply bugging to do
here
we really like the fact that the color I
like these vertical bars without without
serifs I don't like having serifs when
there isn't uncertainty in the x-value
what they Ford you can have it's just a
style of reporting that's fairly common
embarrass you know science magazines and
I know I know I know this is the one I
like in physics I think this is the most
common Wireless without having serifs I
think they used to have saris but then
they dropped them yeah because I think
the surfs don't make any sense
well they specified the limits more
clearly because you may have something
behind their plot and then it gets
confused and when you want to specify
uncertainty on the x-axis then you draw
crosses mm-hmm it's exactly alright okay
so let's see this looks like without in
this case or ellipsis I think those well
I think the surfs are too big but I
agree that looks quite nice notice these
degenerate cases here which aren't too
terrible and actually that degenerate
case is interesting because it reveals
the use of the seraphs see what I'm
saying you mean there it shows that
there is uncertainty yes but it's very
small yes I would just reduce the Seraph
sides by one-third on each side about
about one-third okay suggestion um let
me see what happens if I go many more
points here that's slow okay let's make
that much bigger
that's quite
looks pretty nice so what would happen
if I put an uncertainty on me on the
x-axis as well probably get crosses okay
so here I say around oops
I want to go around of n comma random
real like for me let's say just to be
funky oh I love that time sign coming up
okay that didn't work wonder why I
didn't do crosses by default
well that and those dots are way too big
yeah I'll take a look at that so I mean
this is lists of rounds that were
expecting to be the points there can't
the round be vectors around of a list
yes but so what how would I do that in
this case what I would do a round of the
vector and then I would say um and then
I would give the errors in a vector yes
is that right mm-hmm and that doesn't
mean that means non-correlated errors
but they are vector of errors right
thanks actly
if you want correlations you would have
to specify a matrix yeah
well that's just wild I think you have
an outer level of lists around around ok
well this didn't work well I think
that's I mean it looks like that's doing
it as a symmetric in the y-direction yes
that's right it's doing a symmetric
that's correct it's doing this as an
asymmetric thing just for the Y values
so it's not seeing what that's a vector
there and this is correct by the way
that it should be doing that so I think
this would have to be this wouldn't it
know what that thing is
Splore okay well so there's some bugs
here yep nobody know where I'm storing
this stuff we are certain of that so to
speak okay okay well let's go back over
here so the answer to that is the answer
to the question on live stream event
aerobars is yes okay question is there
in a round version that will produce
candlesticks in west plots this is now
rendering there bears
yes right do you remember this I mean so
not present I mean for the most part
this plot isn't you
what does candlestick chart do with this
and what is box whisker do with wisdom
around I mean it would be kind of boring
I think remind me what the definition I
mean so candlestick has all kinds of
weird stuff in it Milo and clothes
that's it the standard standard sort of
security data right but is there is
there an analog of that I mean you could
imagine some weird thing
what would the analogy would be with
around I don't see there is an analogy
actually no I mean the only thing I can
think of for something like a round
would be you know like you were asking
about box whisker chart where yeah we
would construct something where based on
the around the rotation it has you
assume that I'm going to draw
you know sort of a thicker box ago that
spans you know the 68%
jung-hwan tiles and then knows lines
that go up to 90 some percent or
something yes right it's really sort of
an earth yeah it's it's it's a kind of a
fake it's kind of taking too seriously
the Gaussian but just a one comment we
should make sure that box whisker chart
points to around and so on um okay
other questions from the live stream
that are okay so a comment that was made
there is here let me show you something
horrifying me show you something
horrifying what should this do I mean
probably actually just evaluate it with
the Idol just evaluate it won't it to
what said it's what I would expect okay
but so if the value of okay fine if the
value of EPs was actually zero then it
will go ahead and strip the around
okay let's sum let's go on looking at
these things okay fitting functions
reporting errors that would be so
magnificent this is your free using the
same numbers at the parameter table is
reporting so this could be just nicely
the asteroid understand there are being
combined exactly so perhaps this is just
a CCS having a new property yes yeah
okay the right thing to do if you want
to another property that then reports
this
I wouldn't think compatible you change
it particularly now I agree but I have a
question which has things like fit and
find well okay let's just keep going
here I mean the one function that I
think we absolutely need is mean
around so this is the section Jesus
opened oh okay so so this is an example
of how to compute they mean under
standard deviation and their respective
errors for our simulation of a normal
distribution okay so what's your point
here so mean now I'm just saying that
it's relatively easy to compute
yes so what you're saying here is that
both the both mean and variance yeah
okay so this this is I mean it's Goshen
I think we can do all moments what
you're saying here is that the more
general case is some kind of function
around of you know kurtosis comma data
what is it that you want so what I want
to do in the case of mean around what I
want to do is I've got a bunch of data
here you know I've got some random real
you know you want it to have a different
returned and then what's now you want it
to report it's its own kind of
uncertainty estimates that's correct
I see I mean this is a very useful thing
this is a useful thing in and I want
this to return around like that
which is exactly what what Jose has here
yeah so that should have reported zero I
need to report to that which is
compatible with you right okay so the
two things that we care about with mean
around one is waiting
but being able to wait the values here
now Etienne who may or may not be in
this meeting and I can't remember said
he already has a function that does this
in the machine learning system yes that
so that's a third section there which is
what happens if the inputs already have
errors so the standard thing there is to
convert the errors into weights and do a
weighted mean yes but but there's it
could have weights instead of having
errors see what I'm saying it could have
it could say this data point I've got
seven measurements but you know bill
made measurement for and I think he's a
loser and so I want to wait that one
lower but if there is already weight it
means right mm-hm
wait wait the data it's the wrapper for
it
I see I see I said okay fine works
throughout the descriptive function
descriptive statistics all right fine so
that's the answer to how we wait that's
that's fine that's good so wait a minute
so has attained been using that or not
somebody needs to communicate with that
an about that Sushma um okay that's a
good answer
Roger for how to put in weights so now
the only question is and I agree with
this way of doing it I mean I think
there is no choice but to assume that
the values are uncorrelated
it's hopeless otherwise so my question
here is you know this is a particular
case that I think is very useful mean
around but I think the more general case
is something like this if I'm not
mistaken like you're computing the
kurtosis as an around based on this data
so I think kurtosis and so on a little
tricky because their ratios you know all
the moments are not they're just sums of
powers they say but I mean isn't it the
case meaning it's not the ocean anymore
the ratio of two gaussians there's no I
understand some carrier distribution or
some such other thing right right right
okay so so what you're saying is in a
case like this we know we're lying by
claiming that around is Gaussian but if
we just computed kurtosis we know it's
not Gaussian errors right
interesting but don't we know we're
lying in many other cases right if we
compute some transformation on and
around that's you know a square of an
around number don't we know that's not
Gaussian errors as well well there is
some sort of projection back to to go
sanity though the current around there
is able to support two more arguments
which are two more moments so that the
formulas I programmed are able to leave
Gaussian t a bit in the approximation
that it's really enough some sort of
series expansion
yeah I understand but which is fairly
sensible but I'm saying there must be a
function that you can apply to a you
know a number that makes it deviate I
mean for example very simple example
would be the ABS function the things
started Gaussian then you apply ABS it's
sure not Gaussian anymore but if it had
well the preperation formalism is based
on derivatives so if you have a function
which is not differentiable at some
point it's going to fail okay that's
what it what should happen
ai ai ai okay that sort of things that
is not good what are we gonna do with
this well relapse would work just fine
because it's differentiable where you
want it to be
well what are we gonna do with that case
which I just did well that's magnificent
I think we should deal with this case -
an abscess differentiable there happily
it's just and why did it fail my labs
primer 5 fail when well because this is
the reactive of ABS which which doesn't
know what it's gonna be applied to right
but why doesn't that then evaluate I'm
sorry why doesn't why doesn't it know
after it finds out it's being applied to
5 why doesn't it know to evaluate well
that's a good question so we should ask
that question I don't know who would
know the answer to that is that a
yeah perhaps but it's probably hidden in
the anals and sort of annals of special
functions yeah okay sure there is a long
debate going back there somewhere
yeah probably 25 years at least but
let's ask that question okay but in any
case I'm glad we looked at this case so
what you're telling me is that in this
case even though so let's say I said
this for example okay so that's of
course complete nonsense and that's
actually a good possible issues thing
for the folio fur around mm-hmm yes this
is all based on some sort of local
approximation that works correctly i-15
okay so in that sense there's no harm in
doing kurtosis we can do the same level
of faking for kurtosis so to speak right
so to try something like sine of a round
of something and use three arguments and
there's one being smaller so I know 5
comma 0 1 comma 0.15 comma 1 comma point
1 yeah so so that's going to do a
computation assuming that days a bit of
kurtosis which is this certainly how I
say so this
the formulas here can handle up to four
arguments so sorry not I could toss a
skewness so the third one says Guinness
and the fourth one would be kurtosis Wow
okay cool so this is P but so that you
can now I mean people might be very
surprised if they put in something like
a function around with kurtosis and they
think they're gonna get back seven plus
or minus 0.2 and they instead get back
this weird around with multiple
arguments but this is different
so one thing is computing the kurtosis
which will be a number potentially with
an arrow
another thing is starting from something
that has a mean and standard deviation
and a bit of skinners of kurtosis no I
understand but okay I understand but
what I'm saying is as roger has pointed
out the distribution of kurtosis is not
a Gaussian distribution it's given this
data the possible values of kurtosis are
not you know we histogram the possible
values given that the data the histogram
of the data right if we ask what is the
kurtosis of the histogram of the data
that is not a Gaussian distributed thing
but this is like it's a number of the
data it's a number this yes the
distribution yeah but you guys were
talking about getting estimates for the
quality of those estimates themselves
yes it's the estimator I mean there's
some estimators of kurtosis right point
is that that estimator itself has errors
and those errors are not Gaussian
exactly I mean and and the point is that
we can approximate those as Gaussian
although we're lying so to speak but
it's you know and I don't even know
whether there is a sense in which for
small values it is Gaussian I don't even
know what that means I mean I suppose
that that you can you know the the
confidence intervals can agree
for example maybe it depends what you
want to have agree and maybe there's a
standard for how to do this but for
example the confidence intervals could
agree yeah there's also moment
expansions which you think is what your
formulas are built on right yeah okay
which is a sense of approximation
it's a parabolic approximation so every
curve can be locally approximated by an
parabolic curve okay so the second sense
and so that that would work even if you
just if you don't include it the last
two numbers in in its around so it's
just a worse approximation I just want
to talk about mean around is very
obviously useful but the question is do
we need some kind of function around or
whatever that computes how does it even
do it how would it do it what would it
actually do so let's say we say function
around of ketosis comma data how would
you compute that I mean mathematically I
understand that you take well these are
formulas that are tabulated so for
example the formula for the standard
deviation of the standard deviation and
then I took it from the Wikipedia page
and they don't go beyond that they just
show those first two so probably those
are they only choose that I kind of know
no we have functionality that will give
you that I see not for ketosis but for
these things that are are you suggesting
so I mean and you know we could have a
family look mean around is by far the
most useful of these in fact I'm even
you know somewhat of a loss to see what
you would use some of these other things
for well I don't know I mean like for
example volatility right if you're
trying to compute the volatility and you
want to know what's the error on the
volatility that would be some kind of
standard deviation around am I making
sense
but so so is there a general way given a
function I mean is there a general f
that you could put in here where F is
something which computes a value yes
there's derivatives right you can take
derivatives of F am I am I am I correct
if you can if you can do some kind of I
mean I think this is like but if if F is
a function which takes a list of data
and you know the derivatives of F with
respect to changes in the data I think
you can get the same thing you even did
the same expansion did these things get
very complicated very quickly these are
formulas that central moment types
functions and get I understand that I
understand that time I'm just I'm trying
to understand what the design should be
and I think I think what we should do
for this version is implement mean
around and probably not worry about the
other stuff except I think it will be
interesting to understand whether we
want you know what the right name I just
want to have a short discussion about
what the right name for this construct
is is it apply around yeah I think it is
apply around because it's a oh no it's
not apply its consits more like the
construct case right it's f of data
right it's a round of f of data comma
you know some kind of f prime ish thing
sort of something like that
qualitatively although it's not quite
that what what is the way
we've got something which does a sort of
a and now nerf I'd around what is that
construct called the thing that that
does they around what is that thing
called around replace yeah I'm gonna
have to leave okay um okay
all right so we've got a round replaced
but this is something else that's around
it's more like a round apply does that
right I mean how does that relate to the
erroneous placed construct so this is
more like estimating this function with
around what's in it
yes I mean but you see unfortunately
what I'm trying to figure out is is that
function is going to be applied to the
data house a thoughts and I'm not even
sure we need the function at this moment
no I did we do we're not going to
implement this immediately I'm trying to
make sure that the name mean around is
not confused with respect to whatever we
name this file function
well I guess the question would be
whether we need mean around or some
option of mean that returns another and
I don't think we should have an option I
mean I think that's a mess I think this
is a really common thing that we're
gonna want mean around some straight
thing for the thing that is competing so
what about maybe we should call it a
round function that's common data if
means the only language that we're going
to put there no I'm saying that the mean
around is equivalent to a round function
of mean comma data like that okay that
will be my initial take a round function
it might not be right okay so how many
things would make sense in the first
argument there any function for which we
can do this look look think about it any
function at all that takes a list of
data and returns a number if it has
various differentiability properties can
work here think about it because data so
what we call aggregate functions in
cases some sort of linear combination of
moments because mean and standard
deviation are just the first moments
indeed I mean you can compute it using
moments but conceptually what this is is
the data every you know the data of
things drawn from a distribution of some
kind right
and all this is saying is I'm trying to
compute for that distribution I could
compute the mean of the distribution or
I could compute the kurtosis of the
distribution and either way I'm going to
have an estimate of the error based on
the fact this is an incomplete sampling
from the distribution but the data is
merely a hundred points from that
distribution there is a true answer that
will be gotten if I had an infinite
number of points from that distribution
but this is and there is an error that's
based on the fact that this is only a
sampling that make sense yes but I think
there is a confusion here between
functions that applied to each value and
functions that are applied to the whole
distribution saying the whole list well
so I'm talking about functions apply to
the whole list that's the only thing
here mm-hmm
this is a useful thing I mean it may not
be particularly easy but it is useful I
think with my example of the error of
volatility is an example I mean okay
it's all fake as you go to higher
moments it's the fakeness is going to be
more and more obvious I think okay
anyway look around function is a
possible thing Francisco you were saying
say that aggregate what we mean in where
no having this around for aggregate
functions like for example I don't know
mean total etcetera might make sense
what will happen with total you see
total is a lot weirder that's a lot
weirder
because total is not something that you
know that that's not in intensive versus
extensive quantities in physics so to
speak mean is like it's like an
intensive quantity but total is like it
matters how big that how big the data
set is right it's much less clear to me
what that what that means so to speak
all right anyway that's I think we're
good for mean around and we'll have to
talk about a round function later okay
let's look at so these are comments
about the typesetting so the question is
what do we do when we have something
symbolic do we try to make it smaller as
well I think so for comparability I mean
for consistency I think I think so okay
and then the other thing although I
would like to see um actually here's a
good question on our live stream
how do you do standard deviation of a
standard deviation with distributed I
think we have the wrong people to answer
that question so the the question would
be if we say variance of X so I think
what that would be is expectation a
variance of X but maybe I'm confused
here
I'm not sure wrong wrong people to
answer that question I think now okay
what am i translation with relative
error is 10 to the minus 6
yes so we discussed the previous time
went to change these notation to the end
by the way I agree with you that this
lot of floating above the base line is
wrong yeah I like the fact that this is
more than great but I hope that
parenthesis isn't the parenthesis
probably the same size as those
parenthesis yes I think it's an an
optical effect that it looks bigger
because the number is smaller
okay 90% size of the numbers something
okay um well I think this is really good
a really good way to present this now
the question is when does that happen
does it happen that this size or does it
happen I mean honestly with this level
of clarity and presenting this I might
argue that it should happen at digit 4
other than digit 6 I mean listen as you
know to my great embarrassment I have
for all these years not understood what
these high precision error things
actually represented so I never really I
guess I've never needed to use them
never needed to use a physical quantity
- like 8 digit precision um maybe I did
at some point and I figured it out them
but I'd forgotten in any case but this
makes it very very clear what that means
I think right in the original design
from Jeremy the 89 was also great but I
think yeah it's better if we keep it
black so that it it's more associated to
the number itself I think you're right
I think you're right I think it idea
purifies it actually and we don't want
to give the impression that 89 is
already an error with some sort of error
like yeah right
I think you're right I think - I think
what you got here is good so now the
only question is what the break point is
is that correct well and what happens
when the number is very large
because we don't want those things to
happen the fact that even though the the
error is smaller than 10 to minus 6 the
error is still very large so I think we
need also an automatic transition to
scientific notation yes so that
complicates a bit to think well this
case here I see you can't have trailing
zeros here that won't work yes this is
wrong this is crazy
this case here is crazy yeah well so
you're forcing scientific notation in
that case I think you have no choice
exactly and that's completely silly here
yeah right so d is it clear what the
rules are for for some scientific
notation I think this is follow the same
one of of number form which is basically
six digits because 60 is to be
automatically switch okay I don't know
how that agrees with what happens at the
at the when the error you could still
have a screwy situation couldn't you I
think you can have stuff something
screwy when the error is large when the
number is of order a million but the
error is like 10,000 you can still have
trailing zero digits which is bad right
you never want to have a situation where
you have to trail no I think we have two
independent thresholds one is the
Thresher to from decimal form to
scientific form the other one is the
plus/minus to the parentheses okay
independent yeah I understand but but
okay but my claim is you never want to
have trailing digits in either case is
that true in other words
yeah you better not have any zeros
that have to be translated in to see
what do you do if you had zeros if you
had a number a million right it has a
bunch of trailing zeros yeah okay
now if the error is a hundred thousand
for example how do you represent that
that should be the only way I can see to
represent that it's 1.0 plus minus 0.1
times 10 to the 6 right because other
thing else I think it's nonsense right
because anything else you're filling in
zero digits that don't make any sense
well but we could have something like a
million plus minus 100 yes that's some
screams okay yeah I think it's okay but
but okay so where is the breakpoint on
what is the points here okay so let me
understand so so let's look at these
cases okay so around a million a hundred
that's not obviously stupid okay let's
try this okay that is pretty stupid
because isn't it the case that there's a
rule that you never I mean typically you
never want more than two digits in that
in the error and the plus/minus piece
right right yes and so here we've got
six digits in the plus/minus piece yeah
okay so we never should force that we
never should get ourselves into that
position by default this case certainly
needs some scientific notation right so
what is the break point for so if we end
up with so that's the case I reckon if
we have more than three digits at most
in the plus/minus in the error then we
should go to scientific notation
this is going to be a really wonderful
subsystem the surround thing really
wonderful I mean it's it's interesting
how complicated the whole thing is and
what implicit assumptions are being made
and it does worry me a bit that people
will use this I mean you know look
welcome to the world of insane error
estimates for example in medical
research you know it worries me that
people will use this and assume that the
plus minuses are correct and actually
means something and there really won't I
mean they're really only you know we
have been successful over all these
years with interval arithmetic in not
giving people wrong answers for
numerical analysis um sadly I mean and
you know we had long resisted doing this
kind of thing for exactly the reason
that you know you get yeah I mean what
can we do to prevent what is the analog
of a a you have run out of precision
message I mean in other words I mean
people are gonna get wrong answers
because the distributions are not
Gaussian basically so is that the only
reason I'll get wrong answers as well as
the distributions aren't Gaussian yes
and correlations that they thought
weren't there are actually there mm-hmm
yes but somehow that's in the input if
they don't introduce the correlations in
the input and there is no way of taking
them into account so right at the case
of people who do a computation that
involves the ABS or whatever else and
the true distribution I mean what we
should show probably and the possible
issues is we should show how the actual
distribution gets carved up by you know
by actually propagating a distribution
through right through a series of
functions you know because the actual
distribution will be some complicated
Wiggly thing and we're going to
approximate that with these you know
first second order whatever it is error
terms right
right that there is always the
possibility of using transform
distribution which would get this thing
correct
exactly right right right so my point is
that in somewhere in this documentation
we should be showing people or in some
somewhere gosh it's hard to know where
what form of documentation to provide
this but I mean you know people can use
transform distribution they will get and
exactly correct let's just do one thing
and I need to get going but let's do the
transform distribution the okay there's
a question from Sandra on our live
stream that's sort of interesting yeah
what does this do
what noth is that supposed to do I think
I think this didn't do what you thought
it did because it's a 1 over 1 over I
don't know what how much okay is that
surprising
okay how do we do transform distribution
of the same thing let's see it's from
distribution of 1 over X with X
distributed as that the normal
distribution so is that the correct
thing and two points here I guess the
quiz start really correct actually
because okay now what do we do how do we
gotta get this so now if I say plot try
mean and standard deviation of that
by the way mean around of this should
work right mean around of a symbolic
distribution should work that makes
sense
oh my gosh well that's the difference
okay can we compute this I know I've
seen this computation do amazing things
sometimes but it takes time yeah it's
hard competition if this is an integral
with no I know I know I know
okay well anyway we can come up with
some examples I mean the it's oh well
couldn't do it do you think you can do
the end of it wild and crazy
mmm-hmm so that is to be compared with
one over a round of that which will give
10 and something or other right that's
very interesting I don't know why they
why they integrate failed to converge
it's probably because 1 over X isn't
unbounded yeah it's obvious why that
fails to converge because near zero
whether normal distribution has lots of
support well there you have it I mean
that's that's the that's a great example
that's a very interesting example and we
should we should come up with other ones
like this to show people this has the
particular problem of including serum
which I guess it is what he was trying
to to get yeah yeah I mean look if I do
this for example if I go let's do the
most simple case of an ABS let's let's
be really kind to the thing let's say
real abs of that
okay so now I say mean of that comma
standard deviation of that and then I
say how do I do
can I do any of that thing already it is
already in the machine precision because
your inputs are in a normal distribution
ah
I didn't realize you were here kosher um
okay so this is kind of like go crazy oh
how come that gave a result whereas the
other one didn't does not give a result
oh I see the indication may be easier
say real abs is a lot simpler than 1
over X ok so now that is to be compared
to fascinating fascinating so how can I
can I plot this distribution go show can
i PDF over this yes problem yes so I
just say plot of PDF PDF and then this
distribution and then some variable
what's it gonna look like is it gonna
look like a Gaussian that's been sliced
on one side well it's taking its time no
way yes so you wouldn't need an evaluate
maybe not my well the question what it
might help and other thing is it
we kind of truncate the domain you can
use a difference over but still the
transformation should work okay well in
case I mean it will be interesting but
the fastest might what might work is to
run a random simulations or an ovary on
this transform distribution and thought
histogram yes yes right all right I
think I need to go but but I think I
mean it's really interesting what is
going to work them I mean everything is
going to do something reasonable but
it's it's just unclear can you give me a
guideline for when it's gonna give the
wrong answer is it when the errors are
large or what well it's no I don't think
that's enough no it's it's basically the
fact that we support up to four moments
means that polynomials are up to degree
four will do more or less correctly but
once you are using functions which are
not polynomial some error is going to
happen and the more we are the function
it is tomorrow's control you know but
how do we know I mean the fact that we
have those moments we're not
representing the answer with all of
those moments
typically no there is always here some
sort of parabolic approximation so the
oldest computations work locally well by
by using the day right then in the final
answer we're just saying
we're just going to give you the single
normal distribution approximation to
that answer right if you want more than
that you have to start with rounds with
four arguments even if they are zeros in
the other two that tells the system take
into account the other two moments well
so that's very much analogous to what
happens if you want to have a you know a
precision thing with some high precision
you have to start off with n of
something comma 100 or whatever right
exactly and we can explain that to
people the competition gets a lot
farther because the formulas grow very
fast yeah so what I did is just
programming the formulas mm-hmm straight
so does mean around me the second
argument that says how many moments
Securi could be could be why I see I see
I see so you have a skewed distribution
but then you're going to make a
parabolic approximation to the skewed
distribution in the answer who cares I'm
just wondering where we get a three or
four is what you're saying I see what
you're saying you're saying that mean
around could return a four argument
around yes yeah I I see that's probably
right yeah it would be reporting a bit
more information about the distribution
right so that mean will give you a
fourth-order mean around fourth over
around so to speak I have to say I would
prefer that to be an option somehow but
I don't know what that would be called I
can think about it distribution moment
to order
something like come something like that
I mean there's a moment moment is really
what we need to communicate I think you
know okay super interesting stuff
wonderful functionality thank you to
folks on the livestream good comments
thank you to people here um let's wrap
it up okay okay okay see you'll see em
bye-bye